Hello everyone. Welcome to another members minute. This is Michelle Hamburger, and I am here with Dr. Kevin Connors.
Today we are going to be speaking a little bit about enzyme therapy, and
its relation or benefit to anybody who's dealing with cancer. Dr. Connors, I'll let you take it from here.
We're not gonna go in depth because this is supposed to be a member's minute. I have other videos on this like this one right here
enzyme therapy. They're going to the details on who really started this where it came from and its use with different different types of enzymes.
We know we're just gonna get into the enzymes that we use typically.
So, brief overview. The idea of enzyme therapy with cancer is not to help with digestion.
It's to help break down the waste layer around the growing cancer so that other therapies including
cable therapy and natural keep-type cable therapies can get into the cancer and kill it.
So, that's really the idea of high-dose enzyme therapy. These are some of the enzymes we use but not all of them
because we are so big on enzymes. We have lots and lots of different enzymes. So, we test people on the different enzymes.
This one here is probably our favorite that digestimes X. But we use another one for
heresial health products. That's a that's a big reactant enzyme as well.
But this one I think has got a little more power. But again, we use what tests out of the patient.
Now, these were really created to be digested enzymes. So, people would take digestime
or HCls with their meal to help digest their food. The purpose of taking the high-dose digestive enzymes
for cancer is not to help digest your food but again to help digest the cancer. So, you're taking
these away from food. So, typically you might take them right away when you wake up in the morning
or when you go to bed at night. You can take them during the day but you want them about an hour away
from any food because you want these enzymes to be absorbed across the gut wall
and then circulated in your system to help be able to attack that cancer and that slide layer of cancer.
Now, there's numerous other enzymes I said that are in the U.S.
enzyme line and others that we use that are very specific. The C'sime, the Cera'sime,
the Thera'sime are specific to different tissues. We won't get into that in detail here
but we test people on what's going to be the best one. So, if you came to us as a client patient
member then we might have you on this and not on the others and that's just how it goes because
we're going to test you. We might not have you on any of these because it didn't test out again.
It's not for everybody but it could be a nice little addition.
Are there particular cancers that respond better to adding in enzymes as a therapy?
Well, historically through Dr. Bard's work and Dr. William Kelly's work and Dr. Gonzalez's work,
there are the people who really put it on the map. Historically, pancreatic cancers,
liver cancers, colon cancers, tend to respond to enzyme therapy a little bit better.
We have found that to be true tested conhesiologically. They're more likely to be patients with
those type of cancers that we will be using these on and test that way. But it's surprisingly,
it can be other things too. So, it's a nice addition.
All right. Well, that's a little brief bit and we will talk to you again soon.
Thank you.